there's been this photo online recently
and been a lot of speculation I thought
let's just let's just deal with it right
here the air clear the air you posted
this photo recently let me begin by
saying you look fantastic thank you you
look fit my best posture yeah
what's happening here because some of
the some of the news outlets got ahold
of that well that was fun yeah we'll get
to that okay oh this was it's a bit it's
a bit of a yarn so I have to spin a tale
okay
my wife and I had two dachshunds mm-hmm
Elvis Elvis and Ginny okay and they are
you know kind of they were originally
bred to go after ferrets I don't know I
have to go after um well they call them
Wolverines right yeah they're really
nasty I mean they go after you know
really nasty it's you naked I have no
idea but this is why spinning a yarn a
yarn so you have these two dogs trained
to go after we hear a squabble outside
and then we realize oh Lord the house
has been skunked and the dogs have been
skunked so they were after a couple of
skunks who were living under the house
it turned out yeah and we actually
couldn't breathe in the house but I
grabbed the dogs and took him to the
kitchen and washed them did some tomato
sauce kind of thing and you know tomato
juice thing with some soap and they
smelled a lot better and then my wife
said we gotta get out of here we at that
time we were selling another house while
we were living in this one so she said
let's just go to that house and as we
were driving to that house my wife said
holy you stink
you smell like skunk yeah and so I said
this doesn't really come out honey this
takes weeks yeah and she said well let's
go to the house
I'll make some pasta and I will wash
your clothes but because I had no other
clothes there
I had to become buck and we see you
there yeah this is you this is waiting
for the clothes to dry you say she made
you pasta but that's clearly a takeout
plate right there right it is I sent
that to the jury so it was evidence that
you love wasn't pasta salad from
somewhere I want to know did the people
who bought the house know you're sitting
on the furniture house is for sale you
should put a towel down yeah well you
might be right
we're finding holes in this story left
and right okay took that picture and
then posted it on Instagram several
years ago and of course I found like two
or three days later there was an article
that was run by someone who probably has
you know no good intentions toward me I
won't mention any names and it said oh
friends terrified about Kelsey's
well-being it looks like he's on a
bender with asparagus
[Laughter]
you